so I gave you a fairly lengthy
prewriting assignment
who's actually finished with that nobody
who's going at it halfway done quarter
of the class it's not intended for you
actually to be able to finish it why
would I do something like that that
would frustrate you at the very
beginning of class what does it have to
do with close readings you'll see in
just just a few minutes you had four
different activities one was to think
about something that you actually you
know couldn't a call could remember
couldn't put down on the page and then I
had some more structure and stuff to dig
into a deeper it takes time to do that
sort of thing well and I'm going to
provide you with more of those in I
learn so that you can use those as a
sort of a template if you want to
there's many different ways to do this
kind of activity of close reading so
this is the beginning of the actual
workshop we're going to look at close
readings as a type of writing so you
might say that's a little weird why are
they call them close readings if it's
really a kind of writing well because
with post readings reading and writing
are going hand-in-hand it's what we call
an iterative process meaning that it's
done in many steps it's not something
that you just sit down and do once so
the first thing that I want to do is
before we even talk about what a close
reading is talking about why we're doing
this workshop so how many of you did
anything that was called the close
reading back in high school
let's see okay okay did you do them in
English classes literature classes yeah
that's that's probably where you would
see them now most reading is a technique
that is used in literature
and in history and in theater and a few
other fields religious studies because
it focuses on a text close reading
always a tax generally by a particular
thinker it's not something that we teach
students how to do for the most part in
middle school high school what you're
studying in college English may not even
introduce you to this and when we're
doing it in philosophy there's a
somewhat different emphasis so I've been
focusing on how to do close readings in
in philosophy we're not looking at
things like plot or theme quite so much
as we are safe argument or distinctions
or core ideas those sorts of things so
in the past I used to just assign these
to students i've been assigning close
reading papers since i began teaching
and at the beginning i would just say
well write in there close reading paper
and how do you how do you think the
students did on that how would you do
right I said just brighten it close
reading papers what's that you know look
at the text figure out what's going out
of the tacks
tell me about it how well yeah I
definitely saw anything right because
that gave me a lot of different things
maybe you tell me about the text and the
way that you learn to in your high
school Lit class and turns out I'm not
looking for that sort of thing at all
when I covered it with red ink
oh you screwed up you know but it's not
fair to charge students with spring up
if we don't actually give them the tools
and the guidance they need to actually
succeed so if I'm going to assign close
reading papers to you and say that this
is something you want to do you know as
an assignment in my class it's really up
to me to make it clear to you what is a
close reading paper and how do you go
about doing it so you know I've created
an assignment sheet for you I've created
a rubric for you but even that isn't
quite enough I found
students need some sort of introduction
to it
so last semester I did a video about 2/3
of the way in where they are already
writing their close reading papers and
they want some guidance about how to do
that this is more about the prewriting
process because you guys nobody started
writing their close reading paper oh
yeah have you good we don't watch it yet
at this point we wanted it to be
thinking about it if you have a topic
hopefully you're doing some of the
prewriting stuff already you're gonna
realize that whatever text you pick
you're already doing this process a
little bit so that's that's the purpose
of this workshop the other thing is
there's another purpose which is that if
I'm teaching an introduction a
philosophy class
so really any philosophy class one of
the things that I would like you to take
forth from this whether you're going to
be a philosophy major any of you
considering philosophy major at this
point no that's okay
plenty of other things to study but one
of the things I'd like you to actually
know about is what we do in philosophy
what's distinctive about our craft not
just you know who do we study but how do
we approach things in a distinct way
that's you know related to but different
from what you did in literature class or
history class so I'm having you guys
actually practice the craft of
philosophy at a time sort of a beginner
level beginner to intermediate level by
doing these close readings you're doing
what it is that we do when we write at
least some of us when we write articles
where we write books or we prepare a
lecture to teach in class when I'm
teaching you things it's usually the
product of having done close reading of
say Plato's texts so let's talk about
what a close reading actually is those
of you who have it in
literature classes or history classes
what was it like what did you have to do
yeah okay
yeah that's that's a good basic
structure too close reading did you have
to quote from the text yeah it's called
the close reading because your remaining
close to the text if I had a book I'd
like hold it up in front of my face and
here's where you ought to be you can't
bring in your own ideas your own
approach to it
well it's supposed to be rooted in the
text and usually the thinker is usually
a Texas by one thinker who you're you're
reading you're trying to ultimately
demonstrate to somebody else that you
understand what's going on in at least
one portion of that text that you can
talk intelligently about it which means
that you know if you actually want to be
able to do that you have to understand
something about it right you can't just
copy from spark now oh it's our
Wikipedia or things like that because
you're probably not going to
successfully convey understanding you'll
convey somebody else's understanding but
that may not be you know very helpful
for the paper that you're writing now
I've got this sort of diagram up here
and I think it's helpful for you to
think of close reading as what we call
is a fancy word just calling it
iterative meaning
you're going back and forth you're doing
the same thing multiple times when
you're iterating something you're taking
the product from the last time that you
did that operation and you're using that
as the input so think about
relationships relationships are
iterative how many of you have had
boyfriends or girlfriends either have
one now or have one in the past
all right so all of you are familiar
with fights right where did you have a
perfect relationship no fights
whatsoever now you remember the first
fight was terrible I can't believe we're
fighting you know the whole world falls
apart and then you know now remember
like the if you can the third or the
fifth fight the end and sooner or later
somebody's going to refer back to that
first fight and how things were before
that they're using the past of the same
thing to talk about that same thing
that's iterative in a somewhat different
way than the neck was reading but the
close reading what you're doing is
you're spending some time reading and
notice that with rereading there any
text that you're gonna get to the bottom
of you're going to read multiple times
so you're reading it then you're doing
some writing but that's not the end now
you go back to it you read it some more
and you just some more writing then you
read it some more and you go back and
forth like that that's the way in which
you actually acquire a deeper
understanding of complex text whether
they're in philosophy whether they're
Shakespeare play whether they're you
know suet audiences
history of the Caesars you're always
gonna have to go back and forth you're
gonna have to do some sort of product on
your end on your own behalf to pin
things down but that shouldn't be your
your absolutely final product this isn't
the kind of paper where you know you've
read it everything and now you sit down
on a Sunday night
crank it out you oughta do some of the
writing early on and do more of it and
more of it more of it build on that now
what has to happen in between do you
think you read stuff you're right
what's the glue yeah exactly
you've gotta think about this stuff
that's why I have you write these
reflection papers is short journal
entries you're reflecting on something
in the tags you're tying it together
with your own life you're trying to make
sense out of it you know oftentimes
these texts are two millennia old and
use of what the hell do they have to do
with me you know I'm a college student
with my condition well you figure that
out and when you hear something in the
text that actually does captivate you
and I think the text that we looked at
you can find something at least that you
find interesting or puzzling or even
fascinating you you keep working in
write you read some more you think about
it you write a little bit you think
about what you wrote is this actually
right what else could I say about this
then if you know you do stop stop
writing and you go back to the text and
read it again these are all wait a
second I missed this connection here now
you've got something else to think about
something else to write about that's the
process of close reading now for
philosophy like mostly about concepts
how the concepts are connected to each
other in explanations in making
distinctions all those things that we
called earlier on the elements of
philosophy argument is going to be
particularly important for that so now
what is close reading not going to be
there is a couple other genres of
writing that you guys have done and
you're more familiar with but you don't
want to mix this up with yeah and I see
people do this from time to time
so first up how many of you had to write
the five paragraph essay is that still
like the standard correct
okay throw all that crap away you don't
have to write any five paragraph essays
you can have as many paragraphs as you
like you do have to write in parables
don't don't give me one continuous fluff
text you do have to write in paragraphs
because that's how the organized thought
but there there's no there's no reason
whatsoever that you would have five
paragraphs in the first paragraph would
be this way you know fifth one would be
this way one of the things do you think
just having you know had this sort of
thumbnail sketch what else doesn't
concern you done before what other kinds
of writings have you had yeah yeah yeah
this is not a research paper now if you
were to do on further in philosophy and
you want it to say write journal
articles you would combine close reading
with doing you know some of the stuff
you do in a research paper and you would
probably take into account what other
people have to say if you're writing on
Plato what other people have to say
about Plato and that text and the
arguments and the characters but for the
purposes of what we're doing here you
don't actually need anything other than
the text itself
so yeah it's not a research paper what
else doesn't this something that you've
they written before what other kinds of
things of you
it's not a book report either right
what's a book report light you have to
summarize the whole thing all right so
imagine summarizing the symposium start
at the start these are the characters go
through each speech is that going to be
very helpful for this sort of thing no
they will totally lack focus wouldn't it
you want to find something that you can
do this back and forth thing on you
don't actually need to go back and forth
to do it summary need to sit down the
first time of your summer
what else it's not just a compare and
contrast the candidate have the element
to compare and contrast in it but it's
not just a well here's what Plato says
here with Erics Emma kiss and here's
what he says with Agatha and here's how
they're similar - here's how they're
different
why not you want to be able to say why
the difference is matter and that's
where a compare contrast paper often
ends so it doesn't go into them right
it's enough to just say here's how
they're the same here's how they're
different with a close reading you want
to think about the significance of what
it is here your time so you do want to
focus in on key passages that's probably
something that you haven't done an awful
lot of and other papers that you've
written so far you also want to figure
out you want to be very careful to
distinguish the author's position from
other positions that come up in it so
you know when Plato has Erik Simic is
talking does that mean that Plato is
endorsing Erikson that kisses views not
necessarily all right I mean who's your
best bet to figure with a Plato dialogue
yeah probably Socrates yeah
there are a later dialogues where
Socrates as a young
and somebody else is doing the talking
and there's actually a few where the the
interlocutors might you know make some
really good points but for the most part
yet Socrates is Plato's mouthpiece so
you should probably go there you notice
like in the symposium Socrates himself
didn't do his own talking he like puts
it in the mouth of do you know it a
moment to say these things so you know
you want to be careful with that sort of
thing
and that will come if you're doing this
process of going back and forth you know
sometimes it takes actually putting
things down on paper and the writing
doesn't necessarily mean writing your
paper it could be doing outlining it
could be figuring out who's actually
saying what getting straight about that
in your mind so these are all elements
of close reading let's look now at what
the goals of doing a close reading
actually are so we can think about this
in two different ways
one is by a like you know going to the
assignment sheet and looking at the
basic format requirements yeah and this
is you know this is sort of peculiar to
me I guess you could say but this is
gonna good order for an academic paper
the basic requirements you have to have
a title page why to have a title page
because I don't care what your title is
you have to have a title page because
the title page doesn't matter
you put unicorns or you know explosions
on it you know anything you like I don't
really care you know I might look at it
if you do something really interesting
like that but I don't take points off
and they don't add points in for that
the reason why I have you do a title
page is so you don't put any of the
garbage that you would normally put in
its title page into the body of the
paper because I'm going to read the body
of the paper the main body of the paper
should be at least three full pages for
these kinds of assignments full pages
mean you know begins at the top goes all
the way the bottom one inch margins all
around now why do I have that length
requirement well because
you know for the finished product you
know when you're doing your notes if
it's one and a half pages because that's
all you could come up with at that point
time that's fine but as we do more
thinking you'll do more writing as
you're spending more time with the text
you'll end up doing more writing and
three pages is really the bare minimum
for being able to do any kind of
assignment like this for this this kind
of class probably you're gonna write
more you know you don't want to just
write to the to the bare minimum you
want to explore the topic to the degree
that it needs it don't write like a
twenty page magnum opus because it's not
that kind of paper unless you're like
super gifted with writing but I don't
want you to take away from all your
other classes a work cited page if you
want to bring in other sources which I
do not recommend for these very
beginning level papers because I want
you to be doing your own thinking
putting things in your own terms then
you have to have a work cited page do
you know what what type of references do
you have to put in I don't care MLA APA
Chicago Manual style turabian if any of
your history majors they're all fine you
don't need to bring in any secondary
sources we're going to do this one but
if you want to then you probably should
document according to something some
style but I'm not going to be
particularly concerned about that as far
as the documentation for stuff that
you're taking from the text here's all
you need to do you took a quote from
page 26 of the text that I produce for
you page 26 and you're done that's all
you need
what else
if you're quoting or paraphrasing you do
want to document spell checking and
grammar checking you have for the
finished product for these you must
spellcheck it and have somebody else
proofread it take a look at it that's
all like basic nuts and bolts stuff what
do you really need to do to go straight
what's the real goals here the
fundamental goal for any people that you
rated for me in a philosophy class is
for you to demonstrate to me that you
actually have worked out some fairly
sophisticated thinking about the Texas
that thinkers the concepts that were
we're working with I'm not expecting you
to be at some stellar level I'm
expecting you to be at the beginner to
intermediate level right but that
doesn't mean this you know totally raw
undigested thoughts that means that
you've actually tried to work work at
this but using this this iterative
process so like I put here in the
assignment sheet primary goal is to show
me that you've attentively read studied
and reflected on the portion of the text
of your study notice a little portion do
I expect any of you if you're gonna
write on the symposium to fully
understand the symposium inside and out
that would be crazy wouldn't it you
think about all those speeches can you
keep them all straight in your head at
this point in time I can't because I've
been teaching this for like ten years
but can you you don't need to what I
what I want you to do is focus in on
some portion of the text that you find
particularly interesting that you think
is important and be able to communicate
about it so like I put here you're going
to do this by selecting a central idea
to claim or argument problem or passage
explaining it's fully and
comprehensively as possible there's no
single way of doing this you can explain
the relationships between what you're
discussing and other key
yes you can provide good examples the
entire time though here it's hard what
goes to this goal you're expected to
remain close to the text so you know you
can bring in your own personal opinions
you can bring in your own perspective
but I want what you're doing to be
responding to I'm thinking about how the
text might be able to respond to you if
you're gonna make an objection
Plato got something totally wrong you
should look within the text method as
part of that process I mean you think
Plato's got something wrong go back to
the text and read it and see whether he
addresses that somewhere else and if he
does you've already got some of your
writing done you know you can say at
first somebody might think this is the
case but then when you look at this
passage over here it turns out no Plato
actually foresaw the reader talking
about that and managed to address it
that's the sort of thing that you would
actually write down that shows the
process of thought it's sort of like
remember in math class is showing your
work they still make you do that yeah
drove me nuts because I'm one of these
people that back then I could carry out
a lot of things in my head so I just
gift steps and but I was also kind of
sloppy so sometimes it may be mistakes
then you know since I hadn't shown my
work and not only get the wrong answer
but I wouldn't get the partial credit
for showing your work in philosophy you
want to show your work not to get
partial credit or anything like that but
because that that's what we actually
want is the work not just the end
product but the the work though the
thought processes yeah that's probably
enough event about that any questions so
far and everything is fair game
by the way like 12.5 times new roman' I
like because it's pretty standard I
don't usually like you know not like a
font not too
like that but you know sometimes people
try to use marathons to fill up the page
with these sort of these sort of NASA
days you don't want to try to write to
life you just want to write as much as
we need to what other questions or
confusions or issues let's just talk
about goals we talked a bit about the
assignment sheet the close reading is
what a close reading isn't it's at all
clear there anything that's confusing if
you feel equipped at this point to be
able to move into doing close readings
how many of you by show of hands how
many of you feel fairly confident about
doing these close readings at this point
okay so this is a good point actually to
sort of cause and think about the the
prewriting exercise that you did I have
you first think about a passage because
all you guys have studied so far as
Plato write think about a passage that
or a concept of a blog or friendship
that you can remember how many of you
were able to write something down
everybody okay now what about those
other three things that I'm asking about
how do though if you were to follow
through on those how would those help
you with this process of thinking
writing rereading it down model right
are you able to think at this point what
about passages that have something to do
with maybe support or go against the the
idea of log or friendship that you're
working with by show of hands how many
of you on the spot could at least come
up with one passage that you remember
from the text so maybe maybe about a
third of the class so what would you do
you'd actually most of the people and
even those who can't remember something
you want to make
you've actually remembered it right you
got to go back with the text you've read
it through we've had a class session on
it but now you're going to do some
writing on it so now you've got to go
back and see what you can bring out of
the text that's relevant and when you go
back you're gonna find other passages to
that turn out to be relevant as you're
reading around what else how did you
guys find that anyone started on the
other bits of the assignment we're doing
that sort of thing help you with this
kind of reading and writing process the
thing that's not the only way to do it
we could come up with all sorts of other
interesting templates that's a template
basically very exercise there's all
sorts of ways in which you can do this
the basic idea is you're going back and
forth back and forth and you're trying
to you know come up with things that you
can use kind of a treasure chest of
quotations things that you figured out
figuring out why do yourself are
interested in this that's probably
something important too how many of you
found something just anything in the
playdough selections that we've read so
far that you find yourself responding to
either positively or negatively saying
wow this is really good Plato's writing
to us or this guy is totally wrong about
this how many of you by show of hands a
good portion now do you know why you
responded to that that way
how many of you would say you've got a
good solid idea of why you responded to
it that way
phew okay that's worth thinking about
if you responded it to that line we
didn't get the only person in the world
who who would probably great scholars
out there who when they read that
passage said there's something fishy
about this for those who've you know
looked at it negatively
already Wow things fall into place if I
look at things this way you're you're
not alone in that
and it's worth thinking about why this
actually matters to you that will be
that's something worth writing down
that's something worth bringing to the
text next time that you read through it
that's also some self knowledge that
you're hearing with it
so let's look now bring back from you
know sort of that ideal down to the nuts
and bolts stuff let's look at the
grading rubric I give you this this
grading rubric and any good writing
assignment should have a rubric this
should have some sort of way by which
you can figure out how you're going to
be scoring I highly encourage you
although you may take some of your
teachers a lot to always ask for rubrics
when there's an assignment because they
help you to understand what I'm looking
for what your instructor is looking for
you notice I have a bunch of different
categories here so framing the general
issue what am I looking for you to do if
you look at the excellent category it's
clear what issues being studied and
discussed by the students so I want you
to tell me what are you actually talking
about do you have to do that in the
entire first paragraph of course not you
know you could do it probably in a
sentence do you need a thesis statement
no you don't need a thesis statement you
just have to tell me what it is that
you're actually going to be looking at
all right knows connections or
implications of this issue with other
issues that's that's at a very high
level that's the
excellent category I want you to tell me
why this is important by showing me how
it's connected with other issues
understanding of main concepts that's
really core I need you to demonstrate to
me that you actually understand what
you're what you're talking about I would
encourage you actually to pair up with
classmates and bounce your ideas off of
them understanding of people on Thurs
position this is where I mentioned it's
important to be able to distinguish
between what Plato is endorsing and what
Plato is saying somebody might say this
but I don't think this or between the
different characters don't mix up say
Agathon and pass audience they're not
the same same guy when we get to other
texts than our dialogues how might this
come into play Aristotle for example
will present many other people's
positions and then he will criticize
their positions and say I think this is
good and I think this is bad you don't
want to mix up say empedocles position
on love or desire with Aristotle's own
position see how that's that's important
interpretation of the author's text now
when we say interpretation what does
that bring to mind for you if I say
interpret yeah yeah okay so there that's
part of it how you the writer person
who's actually reading it thinking about
writing how you perceive it does your
interpretation going to be the same as
mine necessarily it better be right
because it's my class I'm not
you've had teachers like that I think
hey when I was in Middle School who
would actually class sessions consisted
in telling us open the book to page
such-and-such at this word begin
underlining and then stopped at this
word and that was the entire last
session just underlining the things that
he thought were important in the board
no discussion of it whatsoever
no questions and then even if you didn't
underline the stuff he would actually
collect your bodies and see Bethany good
underlined properly so you know so then
your interpretation was exactly the same
as its as good oh that's right he also
taught us put a note on the side write
this in the margin there may be rated
books that doesn't work for philosophy
it's important that you actually
yourself come to some sort of
interpretation that you can think to be
reasonable about the text and about
what's going on in the text now that
said you some interpretations are better
than others what makes an interpretation
better than another interpretation if I
say Moby Dick
maybe read Moby Dick in high school it's
it's you know long block isn't that
tedious of a lot of hearts what are some
books that you actually did read Moby
Dick something most people probably read
did you read Fight Club really wow you
guys have a lot cooler high school-level
hate it - that's a pretty good book now
my interpretation of Fight Club is that
it's really about the capitalist system
and what it does to us as human beings
and how we need to break out of it so
that's sound like a reasonable if you
haven't read the book you see the movie
probably right does that seem like a
reasonable interpretation of Fight Club
or alternately my interpretation of
Fight Club is it's all about young male
angst in the modern age and how people
just do things that are violent and
seemingly irrational so that they feel
like they're alive that seemed
reasonable yeah my interpretation of
Fight Club is the third interpretation
is about hot dogs really we all want to
eat more hot dogs that's the core
message of the book and every time
whatever target its character names okay
we will the very namelessness of him
somehow refers to hot dogs and it's
probably the sign that we need to put
more clocks the ideal hot dog is the
Chicago hot dog because it has an entire
array of beans now is that a reasonable
interpretation why not
what are you another philosopher
there are many right
I was pretty concrete good points about
is pretty concrete based on images
everyone's imagining a Chicago hot dog
what are some other problems with that
yeah well what reasoning there is is
crazy reasoning right all about hot dogs
and important you can tell whoever came
up with that interpretation hot dogs are
very important for them yeah they
probably would do that in other cases
but yeah there isn't any there's nothing
that was really based on that you can
point to in the text maybe they ate a
hot dog at one point in the text I don't
remember yeah and then this person would
seize on it see there's there's the
point that that proves by my my thesis
well no it's crazy and so there are
better than there worse interpretations
what makes an interpretation good is not
just that it's reasonable but that's
relevant you want to be relevant to the
text so you know Moby Dick if somehow
you make it about landfills probably
that's not going to work
there'd better be a whip discussion of a
whale in there somewhere right because
that's really what it's about and
nauseum all these descriptions about the
whaling industry and things like that
so it has to be relevant it has to be
reasonable and it also needs to be based
like you were saying in fact what would
be the facts for us with a close reading
so I'm like we're gonna look at it you
know to the world out there the facts
are going to be found or in call facts
here it's a very pollution so it
returned facts they're gonna be found on
the text so if you're saying that Plato
is saying X Y Z you should be able to
find some cancers really saying
something reasonably close to that right
and then you should be able to explain
to me why we should interpret that
passage as referring to that The Fight
Club is really about capitalism then
you're gonna have to do some work right
but there are passages in the text that
support that reading if it's really
about adolescent
and you know angry young men I think
that's an easier interpretation of
support this just about every page has
something you could point to but you
notice that what you're doing there is
you're you're giving an argument you're
giving a set of connected reasons why
somebody should accept your
interpretation so that's that's very
important quotations are paraphrases
from the text I've got some criteria for
that you want to make sure that they're
the relevant ones don't just pick out
quotes at random organizing your paper
that's important and then other writing
mechanics but I don't need to talk that
much about about that any any questions
at this point
we're going to do some more conceptual
stuff it worries okay
so let's ask you this or a deeper
question why should you reread text at
all yeah
together yeah now why does that matter
yeah why does that matter why do you
need to understand what you're reading I
may need to say well because you're not
taking any at the end of the semester
okay that's that's now starting to get
to deeper levels of motivation of value
right
why bother reading Plato if you're not
going to understand just to get through
a class remember class is a waste of
your time really yeah and Plato isn't a
waste of time we know this because lots
of people throughout all history have
gotten something out of reading the guy
yeah and you know when you're an old
person there will be young people that
are being introduced to Plato for the
first time and suddenly the whole world
opening up for them that's that's the
power that these sort of texts him so
you want to think about what you want to
get out of these texts close reading the
reason why have you do close reading is
because this is one of the tried and
true techniques that we have for doing
that sort of thing think of yourself to
start like a minor or spunk or you know
programming around in caves
looking for treasures this is sort of a
set of tools and a man there are some
strategies that you can you can use when
you're rereading philosophical texts
like you're saying first time you read a
text you're reading it just to sort of
like get through it and see what the
hell is going on here
right what's he talking about and you
missed most of what's going on right I
still do even when I'm reading
philosophical texts you even armed with
all the background knowledge I have to
go over them several times if I want to
actually have you know the chance to get
much out of them you want to ask
yourself what is the log that are and
you're going through rereading what does
he often actually trying to do what's
what are they trying to convey to me
sometimes that won't be on the surface
you know for example let's let's use
this Socrates made some bad arguments
didn't mean
from time to time in malicious places
where you could have said wait a second
now that doesn't hold up why to play
don't do that shouldn't Socrates offend
you know like super-smart and never make
a mistake
why would Plato deliberately introduce
bad arguments in the mouth of the guy
who's supposed to be speaking for you
maybe Plato's a dummy
maybe played over to realizing your bad
arguments what do you think just saying
this is the way things are you put in
things that people themselves should
think about in the next Queen why it's
not necessarily the best yeah that's
that's what I that's a good way to
articulate their strong like exercises
where it is they call them these days in
a variety of contexts Easter eggs right
you guys are familiar with this term
Easter egg in a game is like some little
thing you find over here
those are Plato's Easter eggs so you
won't think about that sort of thing you
want to try to take notes part of the
writing process is actually taking those
you want to take notes on the content
the form on the context on what's going
on do your notes have to be perfect no
they're just for you you're not gonna
like you know pass them on to posterity
they just have to get you through them
in the process and they can be focused
on what you're interested in
try to as you're rereading it try to
connect it to your own life experience
your own situation I think with this
stuff on love and friendship that's
pretty easy to do this maybe if we were
reading enough straight out metaphysics
that might not be quite so easy you know
being itself that's harder to connect
your life but all of you you know
experience love and friendship so you
can
later that you also want to work out
themes that that interest you this is
part of why had you do that that
prewriting exercise what bit of it that
I do what are you interested in when it
comes to these two texts that we've read
so far delicious and the symposium what
did you find that if somebody asked you
about it you would like to talk you
would like to tell them about well you
could quote from it or you just you know
you could say this guy said this stuff
and I think it's really interesting yeah
okay there's a lot I think probably a
lot of other people from that
interesting too right
but the fact that there can be different
understandings of these things did any
of the understandings of friendship or
Molly speak to you as relevant to the
kind of things you have experienced I
didn't click as you're reading it those
would be things you could write about my
close reading paper yeah things that
matter to you it was there anything in
these texts where you found yourself
saying Plato it's just a dummy if you
did that's okay when I first read
Aristotle for years I thought aerosol
was a dummy I couldn't stand reading
this is this bums just a common sense
you know parts of it that make sense or
just common sense and the other part
searches incomprehensible it was only
after I actually started reading him in
Greek that it made sense to me I was
actually the dummy dating Aristotle for
this ski is actually pretty brilliant
but you could start from that kind of
starting point that could be a theme I
think Plato is wrong about this or this
is a dangerous idea where people
shouldn't be talking this way that's
probably not where you want to finish
but that's a good place to start for
this process of going back and forth
you think Plato you know is wrong about
something read read some more Plato so
you have Plato has a response to give
you maybe he does maybe he doesn't
that's a valid theme think about the
deeper versus the surface meanings like
let's say we take Aristophanes speech
first Aristophanes speech is about what
these crazy human beings and what the
gods do to them and you know mating and
like you know mixing together and sewing
people shut and then also to goofy
things like that what's it really about
what's the
it's about love what what about love
what did you remember we're always
searching for our other half mm-hmm and
when we find them we want to you know we
want to like hug them and have sex with
them but is that what we really really
want you really want to be pulling it
I'm gonna be we don't want this
unattainable goal for us
very romantic isn't it yeah that's the
deeper deeper meaning of the allegory
that means he's telling you could say
you know what's the deeper meaning of
Agathon speech
Agathon doesn't actually know what he's
talking about but he's great at talking
isn't he you know you can think about
these sorts of things
another thing I would say is important
is trying to get past the I totally
agree I totally disagree kind of
orientation that's okay to start from
you know Plato is completely right Plato
is completely wrong or you know one of
the characters Socrates is completely
right in this plan this is something
that you guys have started doing in your
journal assignments saying well I agree
with so-and-so to this extent but here's
where I disagree that's the kind of
stuff I love to see why why would I like
to see that kind of stuff
making distinctions like that yeah
yeah it shows that you're not just like
lightly grabbing on to something you're
able to coherently pick out what's good
and what's bad and then your going
further is being able to say here's why
this is good here's why this is bad
that's what's particularly important for
philosophy let's talk now about
organization so how should you organize
your paper and I think there's a recipe
for this one single way that you ought
to do this instead of not the five
paragraph essay maybe you have to write
the six paragraph essay dr. Sandler
style these close reading papers they
can be done in a lot of different ways I
think at this point in time you've all
done quite a bit of writing your
previous classes do you use
organizational techniques you find those
helpful what kind of things you those of
you with do you use organization
techniques when you're prewriting
when you're getting ready to write your
paper what do you do they maybe take
make make an outline how many of you
find doing that helpful
okay so quite a few is it is it helpful
for everything
are there other techniques that might be
more useful farina I never had being
able to stick to an outline
deviated myself shows hot wings aren't
that good for me any of you ever liked
making no carts
you put them on the table so that you
can you know like you got this passage
of this passage you're gonna figure out
which which should come first which
should come that you have them on note
cards you can move them around on the
table or you know there's software you
can use like mind map any of you guys
ever use that sort of stuff you can put
them you know move them around you know
sketch out the relations that they have
to each other I actually have a
chalkboard at home that I use when I'm
trying to figure things out
all right stuff up on the chalkboard and
make diagrams for myself you can do that
sort of thing as part of yours free
right some of you are gonna be much more
spatially oriented charts math help you
out some of you are more textually
oriented if making some sort of chart
helps you figure out how to write your
paper so that it actually holds Center
it makes sense by all means do that use
every technique you can possibly find
that will help you out with that
don't worry here's another thing don't
worry about starting your paper with a
book you guys remember that advice the
opposite advice from papers got to get
the audience interested yeah so you're
gonna write about global warming
hurricane sandy may have been caused by
global warming
many people were put out you know I'll
buy it and the damages is you know not
gonna be undone in certain areas of New
York some historic monuments are lost
and they need to start talking about
global warming itself right now if you
do that for Chicago audience maybe
they're not so interested
or you know have you seen the stronger
than the storm advertisements what is
that really about yeah that could be
about global warming
hurricane sandy - you don't need
anything like that for these kind of
favors Glen why not I'll give you one
reason I want you to think about this
another reason I'm already interested in
what you have to say you don't need to
hook me in with an introductory
paragraph that you know tells me about
Socrates in his history or anything like
that plato was a philosopher and in
ancient Greece who lived from
such-and-such a time I don't care I
already know I want to see you guys
engaging with the text practicing the
craft of philosophy why else don't you
mean that's right
let's see introductory we're not all
reading about the same thing it's not
like one focus that we all like
captivating kind of a way to get
attention one what we're writing about
is like coming from our own personal
chess that's an interesting observation
I hadn't thought of that
actually but yeah you're right you some
of you are going to write papers on the
same things but you're not write the
same paper right probably very different
papers the other thing is I want you to
write about things that are
intrinsically interesting things that
you are actually interested in and other
people are interested in and since the
theme is love and friendship are people
generally interested in that sort of
stuff
whole sections and bookstores about that
writing about that sort of thing you're
not going to need any quick to bring
people that the other thing I want to
say when it comes to organizing your
thought work is think about the logical
order of your paper you the things that
you're writing the paragraphs each
paragraph should you know have some sort
of complete thought expressed in it
completely worked out there should be a
necessary order to them it shouldn't be
possible to take your paragraphs and
just sort of jumble them all up now the
paper makes just as much sense you
should be going from point A to at least
point B if not you know point Z by the
you know from the beginning to the end
of the paper there should be some sort
of going of simpler the more crude to
the more sophisticated the more complex
from the surface to the deeper from say
a situation where Plato doesn't make any
sense to a situation what he's saying
does make sense you think of your paper
is sort of demonstrating that you can
move from point A to point B there
should be some sort of logical structure
to that and that's again my outlining
could be helpful or you know these other
techniques because they show you that
logical structure I have this this
handout on seven strategies but I'm not
going to go over that because we're
actually getting close to running out of
time but I want to have time for
questions concerns confusions
all that sort of stuff so the last thing
that I want to say before we do that is
about using outside resources so I have
nothing against you using Wikipedia or
other sites for background knowledge for
you know filling you in about things
going to encyclopedias as a matter of
fact I provide you sometimes
thanks to online encyclopedias of
philosophy I don't want that to become a
substitute for your own process of
coming to know the text through reading
and thinking and writing so you
shouldn't be incorporating stuff from
say Wikipedia into into your papers
every one of you is smart enough to be
able to take some topic and wrestle with
it on your own to come up with passages
within the text that are relevant to
that and to put it together some sort of
coherent whole if you give yourself
enough time if you don't start working
on it the day before it's due but start
working on it now with these kind of
baby step things and then it just grows
and grows and grows every one of you is
smart enough to do that every one of you
is able to you know dig into Plato or
later Aristotle Augustine these other
thinkers can make sense out of them and
say something interesting to me so you
can again I'm not saying don't ever look
at Wikipedia just try to understand the
deaths just for background knowledge
it's not a research at all it's the
research tool for this is the text going
back to that text over and over and over
again also you know I give you handouts
and I give you these I learned lessons I
don't want you quoting my I learned
lessons getting this sort of stuff
because I know what I said about it I
want to see you engaging Plato all right
in your own words with your own thoughts
I already know what I think about it
here that's not and I'm not you know I'm
not an authority I played with the way
you know somebody has published books on
Plato is I just teaches now any any
questions concerns anything is fair game
everybody feel completely confident
about this maybe it doesn't feel
confident everything is totally clear
that's kind of hard to believe
yeah yeah you know that's that's a good
point when you're engaged in this
process of writing you may run into
points where you're saying yeah I'm not
sure if I'm on the right track here so I
would say three things sort of guide
posts or lighthouses to keep in mind one
is is the stuff that you're writing
actually interesting to you you have a
topic have a topic that here you know
you're sticking with that you actually
find there isn't somebody else's plan to
are you are you citing relevant passages
are you making sure that the stuff that
you're bringing in from the text is
actually relevant to the point where you
just sort of you know trying to get it
done jump light things up and then third
trying to always say why you know like a
distinction I like this part I don't
like this part I like this part because
XYZ I don't like this part because
that's saying why that's the basic
structure of argument and that's one of
the key elements of philosophy so if you
start to get lost when you're in the
process of writing and try to like
navigate by those three lighthouses and
that might might help you